We did just hear
a few moments ago from the forme
president for President Trump
calling on those Republican hold
to vote for Kevin McCarthy
and close the deal.
He's warning them
to avoid an embarrassing defeat,
Joining us now to talk about
this is the Florida Republican
Congressman, Brian Mast,
who voted in support
of Kevin McCarthy yesterday.
We should note Good morning.
Thank you for being here.
How are you doing?
Is that statement from Trump eno
to get those 20 Republicans
who voted against Kevin McCarthy
over the line?
I don't think that that's the en
all be all in it.
In your opening,
you talked about it
being a power struggle.
And I don't think the power stru
is exactly what everybody thinks
The power struggle
is about decentralizing
the speaker's office
and that's something
that the Republican Party is wor
very seriously on.
This happened under both parties
Under Republican, in the majorit
under Democrats in the majority,
rank and file members like mysel
or Matt Gates or others.
We got to be a part
of the process procedurally.
But did we really get to affect
in the way we wanted to with ope
debated, things like that?
And Speaker Pelosi,
that's how she had control.
That's how she kept Republicans
out of the process
by having this iron grip
on the speaker's
office and all power coming out
That's what
the Republican Party is getting
That's the real power struggle.
So you're saying
regardless of who
ultimately becomes House speaker
it is going to be a weakened pos
100% no matter who's the House s
it will be Kevin McCarthy.
But when that takes place,
it will be a position.
You can't say it's weakened.
It's an empowering position
for the members of the of the co
that makes it difficult for Repu
to correct course in the way we
because that also empowers
the Democrat members
in a way
that Republicans,
when we were in the minority,
we were not empowered that that
that door goes both ways.
But it's going to make it
a messy two years.
But that's the real power
struggle going on.
You still think
Kevin McCarthy gets there?
I think Kevin McCarthy gets ther
I know he gets there.
How how is by speaking behind
closed doors
with individuals
about what has to take place
in this struggle
to make sure that members
feel empowered enough to know th
if we're
dealing with border issues,
they can get their voice
not just heard
where people are barely on the f
listening to them,
but heard in a way
that their amendments
get to move forward,
be a part of the underlying bill
and actually affect
change in America
or on energy policy or on whatev
That's the assurances
that people are looking for that
they're not going to be blocked
by a centralized power
in the speaker's office
when they're duly elected.
Like everybody else.
But part of
that would be getting the Republ
who did not vote for you to vote
And I just talked to Byron Donal
who switched his vote yesterday.
He says he hasn't
heard from McCarthy well,
there might be some,
you know, maybe some other peopl
that he's speaking to right now.
I couldn't say where
all of that relationship is.
I think if I'm putting this
in a matter of fact way,
understating how these things
go behind closed doors
when people are whipping,
hey, are you going to be with me
on this vote?
Will you vote for me for speaker
This and that,
understanding
that these can go to multiple ba
a lot of times the whip count wi
will you build me with me
on the first ballot?
How about the second ballot?
After that, will you still be wi
And people say,
well, listen,
you got me for two ballots,
but on the third ballot,
I'm going to have to do somethin
I don't know that that's
what happened with Byron,
but I would suspect it was somet
You're still committed
to voting for, Kevin?
I'm committed to voting for
Kevin McCarthy.
He has done the work
in helping Republicans get elect
in laying out a path forward
for Republicans
to go forward
and correct
these paralyzing issues
for the United States of America
He's the right leader.
Does he have a strategy here,
though,
in dealing
with becoming speaker of the Hou
Yes.
The strategy is to continue
the dialog, continue
the debate
with this,
you know,
and not to
to overly use this terminology,
as you said, the power struggle.
But it's like I said, the power
of decentralizing power
out of the speaker's office.
If they're if they're continuing
Excuse me for interrupting.
If they're continuing, do they w
was it smart to adjourn yesterda
Because I had heard that
Kevin McCarthy initially
did not want them to adjourn.
He wanted them to keep voting.
Should they have adjourned
or was that a mistake?
You know, I think the adjournmen
actually fell
under something
that happens more often
than not in Washington, D.C.
And it goes to
what happened right at Christmas
Timing and people wanting to be
somewhere else
in many cases is unfortunately
what affects policy in many plac
There's a $1.7 trillion spending
that went through that McConnell
and others pushed through in the
I was absolutely pissed off abou
especially with the Republicans
moving into the majority.
And why did they do it?
Because they wanted to be home
for Christmas
as much as I wanted to be
with my family yesterday
and those that came in town
for the special occasion of swea
There was work to be done,
and I think we should have conti
doing that work.
But ultimately, I think that's w
there was an adjournment.
So everybody could go be with th
their family members
and their guests
that basically
they got tired of being in there
in the room.
Kevin McCarthy and Republicans
had this closed door
meeting yesterday morning
where he had this
very aggressive tone, saying
basically that he deserved
the speakership,
that he had worked for it.
There were some criticisms of th
that it was too aggressive
and that it kind of hardened
those who were against him.
Do you think he took the right t
yesterday?
I think he took the exact right
it was a it was a tone where,
you know,
sometimes when you're
debating with people,
it is confrontational. Right.
We're still part of the same fam
We sit down together at Thanksgi
and we don't get along with ever
that our own flesh and blood.
Sometimes it gets heated in that
I don't think that it was just o
But in the end, we're still a te
We're going to work through this
and we'll get the job done for A
in the way that we promised.
What does what we saw yesterday
say about what happens
when Republicans are in charge?
I think it shows that we're refl
truthfully.
This is going to be
an incredibly messy two years
at a messy two years
because we're allowing the proce
in Washington, in the Capitol
to play out the way
the founders designed it in a me
where everybody
on both sides of the aisle
gets to be a part of it.
That's going to make it
actually more difficult for us
to get the things done
that we want to get done.
But we're reflective enough to s
that's the way
things are supposed to work here
not the way that Speaker Pelosi
So what you're saying is what ha
yesterday is what we're going
to see more of on repeat.
Yes.
You're going to see a messy
two years in Washington
because everybody's going to get
so in a way that they haven't.
I thank you for joining us.
We'll wait
to see if you actually do vote t
When you convene back at noon,
you say you're still voting
for Kevin McCarthy. Thank you ve